depuis le 15 mars les bars et
restaurants français sont fermés pour
aider à la lutte contre le colonel virus
les restaurateurs qui ont appris la
nouvelle en plein service pour une
fermeture le soir même on enfin une date
de réouverture ce sera le 2 juin pour
les yvelines si tu es encore en zone
orange à dutil ans particulière seuls
les terrasses pourront accueillir des
clients à cette date
pour le reste il faudra attendre le
prochain point du gouvernement le 22
juin
nous sommes en cause en communication
avec césar molina vous êtes représentant
illinois du groupement national des
indépendants de l'hôtellerie et la
restauration
vous-même restaurateur à vercel bonjour
bonjour
alors tout d'abord comment avez vous
vécu cette période
d'une manière assez particulière je fais
difficile nous nous avons quatre
restaurants sur la place du manège
versailles pendant la période de saison
le fonctionnement est pratiquement 50%
d'une clientèle touristique que nous
l'avons pas eu cette année j'ai
tellement et que nous n'aurons pas et
une manières dans l'immédiat nous allons
garder la pizzeria avec la partie et
livraison avant de l'emporter attal et
des libéraux et puis à travers des gens
qui venaient chercher ça directement
ça nous a permis d'avoir une petite
activité est conservé trois emplois pour
les restes et tous les autres
restaurants étaient fermés et concernant
un peu la situation dans les yvelines
vos confrères est-ce que vous avez des
retours sur la façon disons que sa
religion et politique avec le cac sont
dans le même cas
par exemple je dirais que nous avons
juste à côté a noté nevis qui a fermé
ses portes pendant toute cette période
et qui ouvrira les deux les deux ans ça
va ouvrir l'hôtel de lui qu'il est juste
au dessus quitte à 4 étoiles
je partis groupe accor ayant fermé
complètement et pour l'instant ça paraît
tellement ouvrir les non-dits en tout
cas pas avant mi juillet aussi et après
ensuite la restauration géo versailles
jambes plein plein de jolies restaurant
mais qu'une rupture face de petite
taille et ces gens là gentiment bon tout
le monde a été impactée par ce pendant
ces périodes de fermeture et même lors
de l'ouverture
ils ont été apportées puisqu'ils vont
réduire leurs activités à la moitié
pratiquement puisque pour paresser voir
pour l'instant les gens de toutes
petites terrasses la mairie a bien réagi
et l'accorder à une autorisation d
étaler un petit plat l'extérieur sur les
seuls accès public ce qui est une chose
mais à partir du 22 cantons va ouvrir
les places à l'intérieur c'est votre cas
limités donc et ça va automatiquement
l'unité chiffre d'affaires alors qu'il
écrivit limitée de chiffre d'affaires
est ce qu'on pourra conserver tous les
emplois qu'on a en ce moment c'est passé
à tence est-ce que tout de même vous
êtes soulagés par cette annonce n'était
pas forcément attendu un poulet pour
l'île de france
abbas était attendue et par les
restaurateurs et je dirais et par les
clients
moi j'ai déjà eu trois personnes qui
sont passés ce matin pour réserver des
places en terrasse pour dimanche
prochain ses dix matches de rennes mais
pour le dimanche après qu'il a fait des
mers donc effectivement les gens
réagissent favorablement et ils
attendent depuis ça se voit en plus
alors il va quand même falloir respecter
quelques règles
avec les distanciation social en mètres
entre chaque table est à 2 maximum 10
personnes le port du masque pour le
obligatoire pour le personnel comment
vous avez envisagé vous tout cela je ne
peux pas je n'avais pas ça ne va pas
être une contrainte et puis j'ai dû
aller port du masque nous au niveau
révisé dans la vente à emporter les
personnels les pizzaïolos la pêche en
quittant cuisine a personne qui est au
service
porteuse à masquer s'arrête et peut-être
un peu plus compliqué pour les clients
venaient faire respecter effectivement
les pros du masque l'exécution en
terrasse pour l'enlever par contre les
gens qui viendront par exemple aux
toilettes et un restaurant il faudra
qu'ils émettent pour entrer aux
toilettes
nous on a déjà prévu justement un
passage assez large des points des
jeunes à l'entrée des toilettes et la
sortie d accentuer un peu la partie
sanitaire à l'intérieur donc vraiment
adapté à cette partie à cette période
qui va être vraiment karim particulière
et donc pas de plexiglas comme vous
pouvez le voir des restaurateurs qui en
amont préparer déjà les choses au chai
de plexi au niveau de la caisse mais
ceci dit nous on va éviter que les gens
bien payés en cash pour parler
directement les éditions à table pour
l'écrire départ entre restaurant on
appris on a deux ans que fait de porter
d'entrée et de sortie
donc d'un côté les clients paieront d'un
côté pour aller aux toilettes pour
chanter de l'autre côté on va faire un
circuit intérieur où ils se croiseront
pas
donc ça permet de filmer de faciliter
les choses et les respecter la distance
des licences surtout au niveau des
yvelines parce qu'il ya quand même cette
contrainte de n'ouvrir que en terrasse
que vous savez s'il ya beaucoup de
restaurants qui sont concernés qui eux
ne pourront pas ouvrir tout de suite je
pense qu'il ya énormément des
restaurants qui ne pourront pas ouvrir
tout de suite jean par exemple sur la
place du marché à versailles où il ya
plein de jolies restera mais les flics
surface qui ont des terrasses mais qui
ne sont pas énormes
bon la mairie a donné jeudi dans les
accords pour qu'ils puissent grandir et
c'est à dire mais ça va limiter quand
même les nombreux les places sera limité
l'activité automatiquement en plus de
personnes et la cuisine donc c'est pas
rien de cuisine on va pas pouvoir avoir
quatre personnes à travailler ensemble
donc je récupère karim achoui délicate
savez que vous dépendez un peu aussi du
sort des mairies qui accepteront nous
détendre les terrains c'est ce que le
groupement national des indépendants par
exemple qu'on peut faire quoi pour
demander ces autorisations la complétant
je trouve que les génies a très bien
réagi s'est bien occupé de cette partie
là sous toit en essayant des dossiers et
tout ce qui était révision des loyers
tout ce qui est generation de l'ail et
au moins pendant 3 mois
j'attends de voir les des assurances
pour voir si on arrive à avoir un
minimum des remboursements au lieu de la
perte d'exploitation
la mairie à versailles a très bien réagi
aussi longtemps j'étais hors délai par
exemple ils m'ont donné un carton des
macarons des masques sacrés histoire
donc qui sont donnés par les partis qui
généra parle pas paru général parlait
dans l'avion donc de ce couple à la
mairie a facilité les choses
pendant cette période la mairie a fait 1
la gratuité des loyers pour tous les
locaux qui appartenait à la mairie de
confinement non ils ont vraiment jeudi
est formidable avec les restaurateurs
avec les commerçants général et qu'est
ce que vous attendez pour la suite donc
on à cette date du 22 juin pour
peut-être une réouverture à l'intérieur
parce que j'imagine que parfois vrai la
terrasse elle permet pas de faire tout
son chiffre d'affaires surtout quand on
a vu le premier film a déjà quasiment
une clientèle différente chiffre
d'affaires mais c'est chez lui il va il
va y avoir des jours des pluies où les
gens ne pourront pas manger en terrasse
qu'il faudrait reproché à l'intérieur
donc et à l'intérieur on va voir le
nombre est analysé par deux voire par
trois donc on l'aura effectivement moins
des clients à savoir
je suis ici on peut déjà effectivement
rien peu pour nous ça nous soulage
énormément
on attendait ça depuis depuis bien
longtemps ouais merci césar molina 12
est rendu disponible pour répondre à nos
questions que je rappelle vous êtes
restaurateur à versailles et membre du
conte national des indépendants de
l'hôtellerie et la restauration
et quant aux autres annonces de ce
deuxième plan du déconfinement nous
reviendrons dessus dans cette édition